hey everyone it's Mike Balto's from
order flows calm and thanks NinjaTrader
for having me on this webinar today and
today I'm gonna explain how to get the
edge over other traders using order flow
you know if you've been around the
markets long enough you know I'm sure
you've read many books or watch videos
or read you know articles and they all
say you know to be successful in the
markets you need to have an edge you
have to have an edge but unfortunately
they don't really tell you how to get an
edge and I'm going to show you in this
presentation how I've had an edge how I
found my edge in the markets I was able
to last you know 25 years in the futures
industry by using order flow and that's
my edge in the market and hopefully you
know you can pick a few things up today
that you can start applying to your
training
hopefully tomorrow so you know again you
know a brief disclaimer before we get
started I just want everyone to know
this content is intended for educational
and informational purposes only it
should not be viewed as a solicitation
or recommendation of any product service
or trading strategy no offer or
solicitation to buy or sell security
security derivatives or futures product
of any kind or any type of trading or
investment advice recommendation or
strategy is made given or in a honey
manner endorsed by any ninja trader
affiliate and the information made here
is not an offer of or solicitation of
any kind you know just remember futures
Forex and options trading contagious at
substantial risk is not for every
investor an investor could potentially
lose all and more than the initial
investment risk capital is money that
can be lost without jeopardizing one's
for an answer security relax the only
risk couple should be use for training
only those with sufficient risk capital
should consider trading past performance
and unnecessary indicative of future
results you know now we've got that all
the way I mean you know you do have to
understand you know in trading there are
risks there are financial risks you know
you can lose more money than you put
into it you know I just want you guys
come in and understand that you know if
you don't have an appetite for risk or
epi' tightening some money in the
markets maybe trading is not for you and
you know I'm just being honest okay I
don't want people coming in with
rose-colored glasses thinking you know
trading is the way to it's going to
change their lifestyle it can but you
know just be aware of what you're
getting into so anyway today you're in
for a treat I'm going to show you the
easiest way to understand what's
happening in the market so you can make
better trading decisions tomorrow by
adding order flow to your existing
method of trading you know most people
don't understand you know when they use
order flow it doesn't mean you have to
disregard every single thing you've
learned in the past about trading about
the markets know you know you start you
know putting pieces of the puzzle
together you know that's how I view the
market as a puzzle and you're just you
know you're putting it together you're
finding the pieces that fit together
that you know make everything make sense
and my goal for you today is to explain
why order flow matters you know some
people say you know order flow is
nonsense order flow is rubbish
well okay you know you can go back to
you know analyzing the market using you
know your Astro Astro signs you know
where it was mercury in retrograde or
whatever you know there's there's so
many different ways to approach the
market that's what makes the market the
market you know everyone has a different
opinion on what's happening to the
market where is it going and I'm just
going to show you how you can read all
that information of what is happening
peoples different opinions of the market
on a chart in the order flow in what's
actually trading well because actually
you know if you read market Wizards you
know one of the great books on trading
it's you know it's interviews with
traders and you know each books got
about 20 different interviews but if
you've read it you'll notice you know
each person has a different way of
approaching the market and you know
that's what makes the markets move is
people's differences of opinions and I
also show you order flow made easy
you know forget this 10,000 hour rule
nonsense you know I was just on Facebook
I think it was and I saw a post somebody
talking about you only be successful if
you put in 10,000 hours of screen time I
was like oh my god does this person even
realize what 10,000 hours equates to I
don't think so and I'm gonna show you
how to easily spot price rejection and
use it to your advantage how to use
order flow to find market generated
support and resistance levels you know
this is a something I've been delving
into a lot recently working with with
traders on is you know support and
resistance levels and market generated
activity because you know the way people
look at a chart is they look for an area
that price has tested a few times
say well there's your support or there's
your resistance well sometimes you know
support is made and the price never
retests it you know if you're gonna be
waiting for the market to come retest a
level so you can stick your neck out and
say hey yeah you know we've tested this
level twice and we have support here I'm
going to show you how to read order flow
how to use order flow so the first time
it trades there you can see yes there is
support there or yes there is resistance
there and we'll show you a trade setup
that risks just three ticks per trade
you know everyone always talks about you
gotta manage your risk you know I kind
of keep your risk reward ratio in line
you know you got to have three to one
you got to have four to one you know
people always come up with these magic
numbers and you know the basic thing you
got to know is you know just you know
have a low risk and have you know a good
opportunity profit opportunity on the
trade I'm going to show you how to do
this without tons of screen time without
mathematical manipulation of price and
what that means is you know if you use
indicators you know basic indicators
such as moving average you know all
that's doing is just taking price
manipulating it and you know coming up
with a number and you know think about
this for a second okay you know during
the trading day there's information
that's always coming in so what happened
an hour ago so you're using a sixty
period moving average okay so on a
one-minute chart that's that's the last
sixty bars now what happened sixty
minutes ago to fifty minutes ago is
oftentimes weighed yeah just as
important as what's happening now but
twenty minutes ago it could have been a
nice piece of information that caused
the market to move but yet you're still
looking at you know everything that
happened forty minutes prior to that and
you're waiting it equal to what's
actually happening now and you really
shouldn't but you know hopefully you can
understand that sometimes people people
just don't understand that then when
people say indicators are lagging the
market that's what that's what that
means you know you're basically trading
making trading decisions now based on
information from an hour ago or from
fifteen minutes ago or for a half-hour
ago
I'm going to show you how to do this
without messy charts you know sometimes
people they think you know the more
indicator
I have on a chart the better chances
I'll have to make money and you know up
you know the opposite is true you know
the more messy your your chart is the
more confused you get so they say well
my plan is to teach you to trade as a
trader you know it's not to be a signal
taker in the sense that oh you know
we've crossed the zero line on this
oscillator so it's time to buy you know
the the great traders that's that's not
how they trade you know their traders
they they trade based on what they're
seeing in the market what they're seeing
in supply and demand and you know other
things if you stick around to the end I
got a special gift for you it's my
hundred and fifty page book called
trading order flow so if you're new to
order flow you know this is a great
place to start and you know it's not a
hard cut you know I can get a hardcover
delivered to your mail like this not win
it you just enter your email and you
know you'll get to the download page you
can download the book and you know put
it on your tablet put on your phone and
you know and read it at your leisure
print it up do whatever you like with it
so if there's one thing we can all agree
on that we hate about trading it's risk
right you should always be looking to
reduce your risk not just in trading but
in life actually and I don't need to
take risks in your trading you know I
see risk and I run yeah yeah sure hunt
is far away from the situation as
possible you know just like when my my
wife gets angry you know I do something
maybe I shouldn't have done you know
that's a risk I took and you know I know
and I realized it's risky I try to run
away but the markets are the same same
way you know you don't be taking risky
trades you shouldn't be you know risking
more than you could afford to lose so
you gotta ask yourself is trading for
you for some of us yes for others no you
know you have to ask yourself are you
willing to take action you know are you
really going to put what you've learned
to work in the markets you know what
you've learned on how to analyze the
markets you got to make your trading
decisions based off of it you know in
trading there's no regular paycheck you
know we have most people have jobs and
you know on the fifteenth and the 30th
you get your paycheck you know you
always have that to fall back on but you
know if you really want to make the move
to trading sometimes you don't have that
cushion and can you handle
objection there's gonna be times where
you're wrong period in the market you
know you you make a decision to buy or
sell and the oppas market just moves
immediately against you
okay can you handle that and do losing
trades affect your psychology you know
some people like to think that they are
ice-cold killer stone-cold killers but
you know as soon as you know a position
starts going against them and they start
thinking how much money they're losing
they freak out you know can you handle
that so the next step is the next series
of questions to ask yourself is order
flow trading for you for some yes for
others no are you willing to put in the
time and effort to learn you know it
it's not something that you can just sit
down in front of a screen and figure it
out you know you need a little bit of
structure you need a bit of guidance and
that's what I'm here for today you know
is to give you that guidance you know
ask you are you a tiger kicker what I
mean is do you try something for a week
then give up on it rather than try to
understand how it works or the
methodology of it you know you just want
to look for the next shiny object so to
speak and more importantly do you want
to understand what really moves the
market I'm not talking about you know
you got to learn you know the production
industrial production of Brazil or
anything like that nobody you know you
should understand the buying forces the
selling forces at work in the market and
inflection points in how markets turn
you know and how you can take advantage
of those so you know just briefly you
know who I am again you know for those
that are not familiar with me and I see
some very familiar names here in in the
in the chat but you know there are some
people are maybe Newton here to myself
Michael Balto's and you know just a
brief background you know I was most
recently before I started order flows I
was a futures trader vice president of
futures trading at JP Morgan for eight
years and before that I was with Cargill
for four years you know Cargill is a big
commodity trading firm you know most
people think of it as you know a farming
company or food processing company but
you know they actually supply about 25
percent of US grain exports you know
about 30 percent of US meat exports you
know they're involved in a lot of things
you know it's the largest privately held
company in the United States and there
huge huge trading firm I spent three
years at Commerce Bank you know the big
German bank and a couple years a TDF man
which is also a commodity trading
companies an English company so if
you're overseas you know you'd know it
I'm sure motors to you if most people
have heard of man energy and what's not
on here is I started on the CMI floor
back in the early 90s with Dean Witter
and I left the trading floor to work
upstairs on the Globex trading desk at
that time this one Globex was just
starting just starting to take off
project a which was the CBOT 9x access
which was the NYMEX you know that the
energies and you know it was exciting
times and you know there's pictures of
myself here just so you know you could
see you know Hong Kong Dubai Singapore
you know trading gives you the freedom
to move around in the world do things
you wants you know I've got a wife I've
got three kids and you know it gives you
freedom it gives you freedom to do
things you know if you can put the
pieces together and be successful at it
successful at it
it gives you that freedom in life that
we all want I mean honestly you know and
when people hear that well you know it's
great you worked eight years at JPMorgan
yeah it was it was nice but you know
there's a lot of work and you know
trading is work so in 2013 I left
JPMorgan spend more time with my family
and you know I had to make a decision in
my life I was in my 40s early 40s then
and you know what do I want to do do I
want to you know keep coming in at 5:00
in the morning and leaving at 5:00 at
night and you know sort of neglect my
wife and and daughter at the time or do
I want to you know concentrate on my
family so I said you know what trading
has been good to me I'm gonna take some
time off and try and figure out a way to
give back and I started writing a book
called trading order flow and of course
I was trading for myself but I was
trading with the volume footprint chart
from another company it was it was a
ninja trader add on as well
but it was just the basic footprint
chart and I know you know there's
certain types of analysis that I do that
could be done by the computer and you
know just to highlight to me on a chart
that Asian bhai yourself ear you know or
take a closer look and you know analyze
it and then make your training decision
so I created order flows to take the
analysis order flow analysis
to the next level and we program several
tools into the volume footprint chart to
help a trader see price rejection price
support absorption and other market
nuances and it runs on ninjatrader seven
and ninjatrader eight and in all honesty
you know I was I was a big ninja trader
seven fan I didn't think I would move as
quickly as I did to ninja trader eight
you know I went kicking and screaming
but once I went to ninja trader eight I
haven't looked back on ninja trader 7
you know so if you haven't made that
switch you should seriously consider it
but again this is not about me it's
about you I want to show you how order
flow analysis will help your trading in
the least amount of time possible you
got to get from point A to point B as
quickly as possible without getting lost
so let me be clear again I just state it
out there you have to make trading
decisions that's what training is about
order flow is not a red light green
light training system but when you
understand order flow you'll be
understand the market neon decisions
will become crystal clear you'll be able
to make quicker trading decisions and
hopefully better ones so why do most
traders fail well there's three main
reasons you know how I come up with
these reasons is you know when I was
working on the institutional level we
never you know you'd have traders that
would lose their jobs because you know
they had a big position on and they lost
money or something like that but we
never really said that the trader failed
you know because maybe they were wildly
successful before they work for us but
as I started working with retail traders
I saw a lot more people were failing and
you know I sort of you know wrote down
that the three main reasons you know the
common denominators that a lot of people
reasons why I thought they were failing
is one they don't understand the market
- they took on too much risk and three
they spent too much time learning and
not enough time doing and what I mean by
that is you know they sit in Sim mode
for you know years you know before they
actually open an account and take a
first trade with real money and I'll
tell you this right now you know trading
with real money versus trading on sim is
incredibly different I don't care what
people say you know when you have money
on the line you know when you got money
that you have to use to you know buy
food or
I'll pay the rent not saying trade with
your rent money but you know if it's
money that your can't afford to lose
your trading decisions are going to be a
lot different you know when I was when I
was working in the bank yeah yeah I got
a paycheck but you know there's also the
more important thing that you could
always strive for is the bonus so you
want to have good results right and you
know to do that you have to understand
the markets you know you have to take
trades you know ya can sit there and
analyze analyze analyze and wait for
confirmation confirmation confirmation
know you got a trade so the first thing
I'll talk about is why order flow
matters now again you know some people
will say you know order flow is just a
fad you know it's a buzzword that
everyone's trying to make money off of
these days actually you know that just
shows you how narrow-minded they are or
maybe how new to trading that they are
that you know actually order flows has
been around in some form from a long
long time you know one of the top books
if you search on Google top books of
trading you know the one book that
invariably always comes up is
reminiscence of a stock operator about
Edwin was it Lefevre back in the 20s and
you know he was a tape reader that's
what order flow trading used to be
called tape reading you know this guy
sitting around the ticker tape reading
it so you know order flow in some form
has been around for a long time so it is
it's nothing new you know it's just
nowadays with the advent of personal
computing and what's available to
traders as far as computing power you
know it's just taking that data the time
and sales data and putting it in a
different format that's more easier to
understand and one that you can make
better trading decisions so order flow
makes it easy to find hidden strengths
and weakness in the market help
determine if highs or lows may hold
helps you see market generate support
and resistance levels and determine if
prices being rejected and again you know
this information is not available on
normal bar charts like some people will
say oh yeah you can see support and
resistance levels on a bar chart but
what I'm getting at is I want you to see
them as soon as they happen not when the
market trades a level or then comes back
there and hour later
test it and then you can say yeah I got
resistance here no I want you to see it
the first time it trades so you can
profit off of it sometimes it doesn't
even come back and test those levels so
here's a normal candlestick chart yeah
it looks great you know you got your red
you got your green you got your wicks
you know so you know the high the low
where the price open did it open and
close higher or vice versa and you know
honestly when when I first started
trading back in the nineties when you
know candlesticks were really becoming
popular and you know I bought all the
candlestick books or the coffee table
books
Steve Neeson's book yeah two of them and
there's a few others I can't remember
the names off top my head but yeah I
thought they were the greatest thing but
you know when they work they work but
when they don't work they don't work you
know it's one of those things that it's
you know when it works people always say
oh you know you had this engulfing
pattern here that's why the market sold
off well they don't tell you about the
three other engulfing patterns that just
happened in the market didn't sell off
yeah it's always all these it's easy to
play Monday Morning Quarterback and find
out the moves that happened on a
candlestick but you know again you know
when you're making the decisions in real
time
sometimes you don't you don't get that
information now this is an order for
volume footprint chart for the same
period okay and you can see how the
market rallied up hit a level and sold
off but on the order flow if your
understanding of what you're looking at
you can see that there's price
resistance up here and you sold off
right now if you're looking at a
candlestick chart or a bar chart you're
not gonna know that there's resistance
up here you know all you see is all the
market hit a high and started selling
off but if you're reading the order fell
you know that there's resistance up here
you can get short and capture this move
just as down here at this low you know
down here on the on the bottom right
hand corner they're supportive buying
coming in and you can see how the market
went up but again you know if you're
using a normal bar chart or candlestick
chart you're not going to know that but
if you're using an order flow chart you
can see the volume you can see the
numbers that are going through and you
can make that decision you know just as
here on the left-hand side you can see
price rejection as the market starts
moving higher so you know these low
prices are being rejected by sellers
sellers aren't interested in
more in selling at these low prices and
if the sellers aren't interested in
selling what's going to happen buyers
are gonna take control of the market and
markets gonna rally and what happens is
your rally up to an area with resistance
and it sells off to an area of support
and it goes back up now you know not
every chart is as clean as this but you
know this is a good example you know
again you're not gonna get that
information necessarily by looking at a
normal candlestick chart you know
because the way most people trade was is
they you know they wait for the price to
come back up here you know it's got to
come back up and test this level before
they can confidently say yeah I think I
before here before they can confidently
say I think there is resistance here but
if you're reading the order flow you
know that there's resistance here and
you could capture this move and
hopefully capture the move back up to
test that you know but if you're waiting
for resistance confirmation you know
waiting for it to test that level if
what you can do if it doesn't test that
level you're gonna be missing all the
other trades that are given to you by
the market so the second thing I'll talk
about is this 10,000 hour rule nonsense
again you know I was just on Facebook
and I saw some guy posting I will be
success successful because I will spend
10,000 hours watching the market well
you know what's the point of watching
the market if you don't know what to
look for and you know I can understand
you know these you know the studies you
know on athletes you know tennis players
I think it was you know like the top
tennis players you know one of the
reasons why they're so good is because
they spend 10,000 hours but I got to
tell you there's you know the cream in
that crop you know rose to the top
there's a lot of other players that are
still kind of crummy that spent ten
thousand dollars I could sit in front of
a piano for put ten thousand hours and
let me tell you I'm not gonna be that
good at it I can be able to play but I'm
not gonna be no Mozart or anything like
that but if you break down what 10,000
hours are you know what it works out to
it's eight hours a day five days a week
forty four weeks of the year it's five
and a half years okay
no one is gonna hire you to do a job and
give you five years five and a half
years to figure it out you know if you
go to work at a company yeah you've got
a grace period of you know maybe three
months something you know to figure out
you know be able to do your job if you
can't do it they're not gonna keep you
around I kind of say well you know it's
ten thousand hours before he gets good
at his job
know that that's not gonna happen and
you know with the order flow once you
understand the basics of order flow you
know it'll really start you know the
pieces will start falling in place and
you'll begin to understand what you're
looking at in the market so this is an
order flow volume footprint chart and it
looks intimidating but let me just tell
you it's not and there are three things
the three building blocks that I call
them that you need to focus on the point
of control which is the point in the bar
with the most volume and it's usually
got a rectangle around it a ninja trader
eight I have it grade so it's a little
bit easier to see the Delta which is on
the bottom and what the Delta is it's
the net difference between aggressive
buyers and aggressive sellers in that
are and imbalances well what's an
imbalance is when you have more
aggressive buyers than sellers on the
bid in the offer
all right markets are a two-way auction
so again we just explained it here so
you can understand put a control simple
the price level in a bar with the most
volume and why is that important is
because you know as markets start to
move that will often become your support
level for the next bar or your
resistance level for the next bar Delta
is the net difference between aggressive
buyers and aggressive sellers in a bar
so remember markets are two-way auctions
so for example here in the middle you've
got the bid side this is all the volume
traded on the bid on the offer side this
is all the volume what traded on the
offer
all right you add those two numbers up
if it's positive you have positive Delta
so you have net aggressive buyers if
it's negative like this bar here minus
43 you had more sellers more aggressive
sellers rather in the bar and what's the
difference between aggressive buying an
aggressive selling is you also have
what's called passive buying and passive
selling so remember
to a auction you have a bid you have an
offer say the market is one bid at two
you're trying to buy ones someone else
is trying to sell twos
okay now markets not going to move
unless one person either the seller
lowers his price and his aggressive and
sells into the bid or the buyer becomes
aggressive and buys the offer so when
that happens when the seller lowers his
price to one and sells the one bid then
he is the aggressive seller if the buyer
went from one it moved his price up and
bought the twos he is the aggressive
buyer hey I think I said the wrong thing
before so when the seller at two goes
down to one he's aggressive seller when
the buyer at one moves his price up to -
he's the aggressive buyer and when
imbalance is when you have more
aggressive buyers than aggressive
sellers or more aggressive sellers than
aggressive buyers in the two-way auction
by at least four to one and what it
looks like on the volume footprint chart
is it'll be a blue number right in the
bar or a red number if it's aggressive
selling so buying will be blue bar a
blue number aggressive selling will be a
red number so as you can see here one
against 119 that's more than four to one
so the 119 is blue
that's your imbalance of buying
imbalance now the next price is 320
against 153 that's not you know 153
against 320 is not more than 4 to 1 or
the 320 is not more than 4 to 1 over the
153 so it's not a blue number either one
or it's not a red number now selling the
balance up here you can see here's a
little cleaner 31 against 145 that's a
sign of balance because you have more
aggressive selling into that bid 1
against 20 the only one traded on the
offer 20 traded on the you had a
lot of aggressive sellers selling into
that bid three against 43 is you know 40
is more than four to one against three
so you know yes you have more aggressive
sellers into that bid and you know
there's something else that's called a
stack imbalance and just really quick
and what that is is when you have three
or more imbalances literally stacked on
top
of each other one two three minimum in
this case there's four yeah you could
have more but let's generally you know
three is that is the cutoff now again
you know this ratio of four-to-one it's
not set in stone that's sort of like the
industry standard now when I launched
the order close trader software created
what I call ratios and ratios help you
determine if price levels are being
rejected or defended and there are two
types of ratios there's a racial balance
high which indicates prices being
rejected or a ratio bounce low which
indicates price is being defended and
how it looks on the volume footprint
chart this is the order flows trader
again it's is unique to my software my
software has a few extra order flow
analysis tools that regular volume
footprint charts just don't have and you
know that's why I created this order
flows I say created it for my own use
but then you know I was talking to
people people like Amy that's great you
know I should try it getting it out
there for the markets you know for fur
traders to use you know that really
wasn't my intention you know I just
wanted to keep it for myself but then
you know people kept bugging me and how
need me said hey can you make it
available so I said sure and you know
actually some people have been starting
to copying it and adapting it to their
own software and you know oddly enough
they'd like to try and claim ownership
to it they want to say oh this is the
old order flow algo deluminator or
whatever garbage name you know but it's
just a simple thing and what it does is
it reads the order flow in the bar and
really simple a number will appear above
or below a bar if it's a blue ratio this
is number here you see the arrows
pointing to them so on a green bar on a
bar that closes higher then it opens it
will always appear below if it's a red
bar you know a candle that opens and
closes lower it'll be above and it I did
that because you know it's for me it's a
visual thing you know if I'm looking to
buy and we'll be looking below the bar
to see what the number is if I'm looking
to sell be looking above to see what the
number is and if it's a black number
that's just your normal order flow right
it's nothing special about it because
you know not at every price level or
every bar there's going to be something
actionable something to make a decision
off of but on some bars you're gonna see
a blue ratio a balloon
and that's important to note right again
you'll take things in context of the
market you know where it's appearing you
know we had a swing lower swing high you
know things like that you know again
don't it's not a red light green light
system you still gotta make decisions
you know if you're seeing price support
or price rejection at a low yeah you
probably want to be taking a trade you
know if you see price resistance at a
high yeah you probably want to be
getting short so again you know where
should you be looking at this you know
anytime a market makes a higher low you
should be asking yourself is the market
going higher or is the market going
lower and what are you gonna look for
you know what's going to be your signs
that the markets gonna turn or the
markets gonna go higher but so we'll
talk about what causes the market to
turn is either price resistance or price
rejection and what this price rejection
again you know it's you're getting a
height to a level all right and price is
quite high you know if you're at the
height of the day you have to hide the
day prices are high and usually traders
will be asking you know do I want to pay
this price or not if not they're
rejecting that price so if you don't
have buyers buying at those higher
prices anymore who's gonna buy the
market's going to come off naturally and
you can see here on this chart you got a
bearish ratio you got a ratio bounce
high it's above the bar so I know that I
should be looking at potentially getting
short and I could see the number it's a
blue number so I know I got a blue ratio
that's you know I can be taking that
high and say to myself that yeah I think
you know I see prices being rejected you
know we can probably start to come off
and we do we come off now here's another
one you know we hit a swing high you
know big move up you know positive Delta
all green candles aggressive buying you
see buying imbalances then you get up
here you got your alone red candle okay
yeah just because you have a red candle
in the middle of a move up you know
doesn't necessarily mean the move is
over but if you can use the order flow
if you could read the order flow and see
hey I've got price rejection up here I
know that traders are now rejecting
these prices up here you can be fairly
confident in taking a short
again you don't watch them at swing lows
or it lows of the day you know we're
coming down here it's just kind of
bouncing around you have swing high
here's price rejection come down here
price rejection test the level don't
make a new low start going up you see
price rejection in this part with the
blue number or the blue ratio is heavy
blue ratio here and then we start
rallying quite nicely and again you know
this is a four range chart it works on
its a eight range chart you know that's
the 8 range chart we're setting minute
based charts it works on range based
charts it works on basically any chart
type you know I don't look at wrinkled
charts that much anymore but I'm sure
there are some people that that do use
it with my software because I know I've
gotten questions on it and you know once
the ones that you got my answer they go
okay yeah that makes sense now but again
you don't watch ratios and swing lows
and just not just at the low but watch
what happens after a low okay you know
sometimes people are so fixated out
looking at a low for signs that they
miss the sign right after right after
the low is made and it's the perfect
example
okay this market is selling off you come
down into a low there's nothing on this
low in the order flow telling you
necessarily to get long
there isn't a delta but that's another
presentation but you know we start going
up but as you're starting to go up you
can see this bar here you've got a
bullish ratio bullish raishin bullish
ratio this is a racial balance high
racial balance low ratio bones high
ratio bonds high indicates price
rejection this is ratio bonds low
indicates price support this bar here is
got price rejection and you know what
that means okay so you're coming down
into your low you hit a low you start
ticking up and you've seen traders
rejecting this low you start coming up
you see aggressive buy past strong
support passive buyers coming in bidding
this market you know 1274 here is that's
a strong volume number markets not
selling off anymore so now you have
support you get up here next bar there's
support down here but you also seen
price rejection you don't have those
traders trying to sell in
and push it lower because they're
rejecting those prices and then the
market moves higher you know just really
quick when I was talking about pointed
controls you know on a market that's
moving up you should be watching the
point of controls are we making higher
pointing controls on the move up you
know that's the sign of a move market a
healthy move up just as on a move down
you should be looking at pointing
controls being lower on the move down
and again you know it's this move yet
remember what the movie was but it was a
great quote
it says the guy says to the detective
you know you're looking for clues but
you're missing all the signs and again
you know so if you're just looking at
swing highs or swing lows specifically
and you're missing you know all the
signs in the market that the market is
telling you that this market is ready to
rally alright because you're just
looking well I'm only interested at the
low to see what happened well not you
know take everything as it's happening
and use that information to make your
trading decision and you know in the
past I used to calculate these ratios in
my head and a calculator but one of the
reasons why I created the order flows
trader software was to let the computer
do the heavy lifting for me you know do
the calculations for me so all I could
have to do is I just got to look at the
number and it does that it did that
analysis I could say okay yeah that
that's a number I should I should be
looking at this you know potentially
start to move up or you know here you
got a price rejection that the markets
gonna start moving down and you know by
doing that calculation it takes some of
the heavy lifting off and what I mean by
that it does the analysis for me that I
know what numbers you know what ratios I
like and if it's blue it's a ratio that
I like now I could look at other things
other nuances in the order flow to make
trading decisions and you know I've
found you know trading around the ratios
have always given me low risk trading
opportunities I mean this is how I've
traded for years now the third thing
I'll talk about is to how to easily spot
price rejection and use it to your
advantage and again you know price
rejection doesn't always appear it's
like finding sometimes it's like finding
a needle in a haystack
you know you need you know if you could
have something a tool that will help you
find that needle in the haystack
sometimes then great
so how do you spot price rejection well
it's a ratio bounce high so it's a blue
number it's a certain type of blue
number again there's there's different
types you know there's a number that's
above where like what I call that's why
it's called ratio bones
high is it's above a certain number so
it's a higher number means price
rejection and the opposite is true for
support it's a racial balance below but
I want to talk about is price rejection
so I'm looking for ratio pounds high so
basically a number a ratio above 30 so
you see these other numbers here 3/5
12-point onine 1.01 3 they're not blue
is because they're not above 30 now on
this an order flow straighter software
you could set what level you want I have
it set at 30 so I know that if it's
above 30 it'll be blue and it's it the
reason is blue is to a draw my attention
to it ok so here you have a market
selling off you get down to a low and I
got a ratio indicating price rejection
then the market rallies up here okay
that's you know that's the beauty of
order flow you saw price was rejected
here so you catch this move you know
you're not waiting for price to test it
or anything like that no you know right
there right away price was rejected okay
here's another example mark is just
moving sideways not doing much of
anything and all of a sudden you seen
some signs of price of rejection appear
at this last bar what happens these
lower prices here are starting to be
rejected for the first time and how many
bars starts moving higher it makes a new
high comes back in was it do comes back
in throws up another sign of price
rejection then the market makes the move
you know over the next five minutes and
rallies quite nicely
you know that's this is what I'm talking
about when I say market generated
information
so here's spotting price rejection you
know here's a market was just sort of
going sideways then you see a sign here
price rejection is a bullish ratio 203
535 right down here right off this low
it's not on the lowest right after the
low then here you have a racial balance
low which indicates price support then
you got another bar here with a bullish
ratio 43 it's a racial balance low sorry
I racial balance high this point to one
1/2 is a racial balance low the racial
balance low is a number below points
or whatever you set it at I use point
seven and that will indicate support so
you're rallying up right yeah he's got
some price rejection so you don't have
sellers interested in selling you get to
this level big buyers you know people
that support the market and move the
market realize that hey you know these
lower prices are being rejected market
is gonna start rallying so they start
bidding the market up you have your
support market test that level rejects
that that lower level and what happens
boom these are those two bars right here
this one and this one is right here you
can see over the next this is a minute
chart you know from 856 to 903 you get a
nice you know three-point move over the
next point is that seven minutes so you
know hopefully by now you should
understand how to see price rejection in
the market using order flow so you know
the fourth thing I'll talk about is how
to find market generate support and
resistance levels again you know the
easy way is well you know what most
people do is they they look for a market
they like to look for areas on the chart
they look look left and that's fine you
know you look left you know it's not
gonna kill you to look left on the chart
and what they're looking for areas where
the market likes to test it and I'll say
that's support or that's resistance but
if you use order flow you can spot it
the first time it happens and why is
that useful is because that's useful
because when it trades there the first
time you can take a trade right then you
don't need to wait for the market to
retest if you want to wait you know yeah
you could sit there you throw your bids
in there you know for if it's support or
throw your offers in there if you know
that's resistance and let the market
test those areas then make them move so
here prices support there's a one-minute
crude chart come down in here you have a
bullish ratio yeah at this low area and
it's a racial balance below which
indicates price support so if you can
get long right away or you could wait
for the retest you know because you know
that there is supportive buying here
chances are there may be supportive
buying once you retest that area so you
can be sitting in here with a bid you
know so you're not waiting for it to
come in here test it and then start
rallying and say yeah you know everybody
tested that no you can be sitting right
there today take advantage of it I mean
you take advantage of it as soon as you
knew what happened as honestly sometimes
you know these the markets don't retest
those lows those support areas or those
resistant areas in this case we did
retest it and then made the move higher
you know this is an example markets sold
off quite nicely hit an area of support
is it racial violence low market didn't
test that level I mean it came down
within a few ticks and rallied but again
you know if you're using order flow you
can know you can see that there is
supportive buying right here okay so you
could you get long you know you could
also throw in another bid you know
somewhere in you know closer to that
lower area for a retest but again you
know if people like to wait for the
market to retest that level you know in
this case the market never retested that
level and you never caught the move but
if you're using order flow you know you
could get long and you catch that move
you could participate you know here's
here's an example price resistance so
you got racial balance low here on the
left hand side and you sort of come back
up test it then you start coming off
again and in this bar all right say
you're not convinced that this is
resistance for some whatever reason so
you're not convinced of this high as
resistance as you start coming off that
high you have a racial balance low
indicating that there is resistance up
there and you know there's people
stopping the market you know for
whatever reason people have supplied a
cell and you can catch that so again you
know if you miss it earlier you catch it
as you start coming off you can say hey
you know what there's resistance and you
catch this nice move down again this is
also a 1-minute chart you know you're
talking to move from 60 408 down the you
know 63 80s you know that's a nice move
over the next and you're just talking 1
2 3 4 5 6 minutes you know the next five
minutes you get twenty some points up in
the market and you know one again you
know one of the areas where people get
lost on sometimes is when they think of
support and resistance they only think
of it appearing at highs or lows or
swing highs or swing lows but
you have what's called supportive buying
in the market you have resistant selling
in the market and what that is is you
know an moves up you have people bidding
the market you know they're supporting
the market or on moves down they're
offering resistance they got supply and
they're not necessarily pushing the
market lower but you know they're
capping the market they're putting the
resistance out and they're putting their
offers out there so if anybody wants to
buy they gotta buy from them and they've
got a lot of supply to sell just as
supportive buying comes in as the market
starts moving higher is you know you got
people that you know are happy to pay
you know work a bid you know if the
market you know if they're sellers just
want to come into you know to sell it
sell to their at their price you know
they're happy to take all that and
that's what supportive buying is so
oftentimes it moves up and moves down
you get supportive buying or resistant
selling Zhai moves down you can see how
it appears here on this move higher you
have a racial balance low indicating
supportive buying you hit your swing
high you start coming off you got
resistance selling in here you to bars
later you test that area and you sell
off that's what sort of buying and
resistance selling that looks like so
the last thing I'll talk about is the
straight setup that risks just three
ticks per trade now I'm not saying you
know it's this is the Holy Grail or
anything like that because sometimes
this trade doesn't even appear on the
date again it depends on your chart
piasa tea and you know the market your
training and sometimes you know your are
you can have two or three losers yeah
but you get a nice winner that makes it
all up I mean but again it's it's you
know it's nothing's guaranteed in the
markets we all know that and I called
this trade the o2x trade and why is it
called the Oh two x's I'll get that in a
minute but it's a three tick stop setup
and it has very low risk because you
know where you can hide behind when
taking the position and here's the rules
right it's what you do is you look for
the daily high or low swing high or low
the ratio bounce high at that high which
indicates price rejection or racial
balance low which indicates price
support so basically you're looking for
a blue number at a high or blue
alone you place your limit two ticks off
the higher low to get into the trade you
place you to stop three ticks away for
your entry so here it is here's an
example and why is the why it's called
the o2x is you have your lo imagine you
put a circle around it and it's called
the o 2x not a circle 2x but any put
your euro or around it you place your
stop two ticks off the low I saw your
face you buy limit two ticks off that
low you place your stop just below that
low so you're risking three ticks okay
from your from your entry price your
limit bid
so you can see here it came back down he
fills you then rallies back up and
that's o to the X is that kind of
treasure map x marks the spot you know
your profit target is your X here's
another example
here's your low you got your bullish
ratio it's either a racial balance
higher ratio bonds low you're looking
for basically you're just looking for
the blue number on the order flow and
that's euro you put your limit two ticks
up off that high and your stop just goes
one tick below the low so you're just
risking three ticks first time came down
maybe you could have got something in
there and rallied up second time this
case he did give you a second chance and
it made a nice little move higher again
so hopefully by now you can see how
powerful order flow analysis is do you
think it's difficult or easy I hopefully
you think it's a lot easier than you
first imagined and again you know
everyone says keep it simple I agree
with that keep it simple and order flow
is about as simple as it gets
so if you found this helpful I think you
really liked my order flow as a trader
software package you know it's the
easiest and fastest way to trade with
order flow and you should choose
consistency and control of your trading
again your trading is not based on luck
or being special once you understand
what's happening in the market you'll
find the market just makes sense you
don't have to spend ten thousand hours
of screen time taking an unnecessary
risk and most importantly wasting your
money you know I always see these people
yeah I blew up three accounts geez you
know what you learn how to trade first
before you start trading and blowing up
accounts you know that that's what I
don't want you to do I don't want you to
blow up your accounts I want you to you
know limit
risk understand what's happening in the
market and make better trading decisions
you know just a little backstory about
myself you know I worked in a future
trading business you know for 20-25
years you know what euro we know how
hurt 2018 I started in the early 90s but
before I got into it I was managing a
grocery store
and why is because I want to go to
college I worked in a grocery store and
you know after college they offered me
basically a management position and you
know the money was decent you know
you're in your when you're 21 years old
making the only the 30,000 s you think
you're a bother but then I realized you
know I had to make a decision is this
what I want to be doing with the rest of
my life again there's nothing wrong with
working the grocery store I saw that a
lot of friends at work in grocery stores
and they're quite successful you know
they live great lives but it's not
really what I wanted to do I didn't want
to do that I had different aspirations
and like I wanted to become a trader so
I got a job on the seamy floor making 25
cents above minimum wage because I
worked for Dean Witter and you know they
figure I guess if they're paid 25 cents
more they would get better better
quality better quality people working
for them and you know the point of the
story is you have to break your old
habits if you want to make a change so
that's why I put together this package
the order flows soft trader software
package so if you're ready to do this
yourself you know type yes in the chat
and what the oracles trader software
package is it's it's software and
education so the software package
portion of it is that you saw the charts
in this presentation they're generated
with the order flows trader it runs on
ninjatrader 7 or ninja trader 8 and it's
a volume footprint chart but what's a
bit different is it has four
pre-programmed order flow indicators
programmed in it ok and today I just
talked about the ratio balanced high
ratio bombs low there are other ones in
there if you go to my website you can
learn more about them and I will also
give you my chart template so you know
your your screen can look just like mine
you know it's that that's where people
give up on order flow is they can't even
set up the charts properly sometimes and
you know cuz one they don't know what to
look at and two since they don't know
what to look at they don't know how to
set up their charts and they just give
up on
and it's a shame because you know order
flow is a great way to approach the
markets so I'll give you also my chart
templates so your charts gonna look just
like mine but again you know having
order flow trading software is one thing
the next thing is you have to know how
to use it right because what's the point
of getting it spending a lot of money on
something that you don't know how to use
it's like buying you know those those
fancy DSLR cameras but running it in
automatic mode if that's the case just
use the the camera on your phone you
know you don't need to spend a thousand
or so on you know on a fancy camera with
all the bells and whistles if you're
just gonna run it in automatic mode and
yeah it's sort of same thing as like
with order flow if you don't know how to
use it what's the point you know just
stick to bar charts but what I have for
you is a lot of Education you know
that's really what I think separates me
from a lot of other software is you get
a lot of education on how to trade with
order flow so how you didn't know what
to look for
you know the little nuances in the
market and what nuances in the order
flow and so you can also get access to
the order flows training course which I
normally sell for 297 and I sell it like
all the time on my website almost every
day to I get a sale on it and it's three
hundred dollars it's twenty twenty
lessons it's fifteen hours of video
instruction so you can download it to
your phone to your tablet or whatever
you know here at PC and watch it at your
leisure and watch it over and over again
yeah I didn't expect it to be so long
but I started recording these things I
wanted like a six hour course but then
there's just a lot of information I
wanted to impart that you know just it
just ended up being fifteen hours so
instead of you know watching it on
Saturday afternoon be your Saturday and
Sunday but you know the real bone is the
real bonus to this whole package is the
access to the order flows inner circle
which you'll get for free
it has 55 videos and an advanced order
flow analysis it's on order flow
analysis it's not oh how to use a
trendline you know or something like
that no it's it's on order flow so if
you're really interested in order flow
this is something you really want to
consider getting access to and and I
honestly I don't really open it up for
the public maybe once or twice a year
that because you know I only want people
that are serious about order flow in it
you know and the other bonus that's
inside the inner circle is you get
access to my indicators my additional
indicators for free you know that
indicators I normally sell for you know
anywhere between 200 to 300 to 400
dollars you get those free and whatever
new indicators are released members of
the inner circle get for free so I
probably got one coming out in by about
six weeks and so you know if you
remember the inner circle you'll get it
you need access to it at no additional
charge these are my proprietary tools
and and my knowledge you know that
you're not gonna get anywhere else so
what is it you know it added up you know
the order flows trader software itself
for $8.99 the training the order flows
trading courses 297 the inner circle is
normally 997 when it's available but you
know for just a one-time payment you
know I sound like one of those
infomercials but one-time payments wait
there's more but you know honestly you
know you can ask yourself you know I do
you want to make a change in your
trading do you want to make a change in
your life you know it's 1250 you get
access to all that information and put
it in perspective all right what can you
spend $1,250 on you get the new iPhone X
actually I was reading that you know
iPhone is going to phase out or
discontinue the iPhone X this year I
think because I got another one coming
out later this year but yeah then what
you know in the next year or two you got
to change your phone anyway would you
rather spend it on something that you
got to change or you know invest it in
yourself you learn how to act learn how
to read what's going on in the markets
you know I always think you know it's
it's one of those things you should
really spend it on yourself
it's nice to have a nice phone or
something but you know spend it on
yourself again go to order flows calm
/all and what it does it takes you to
this page you scroll down and takes it
this button here I mean if you you could
read everything on the page now there's
a lot there's videos on there and you
knows a lot of charts and examples of
the other indicators programmed in the
order flow trader click on I'm all-in
and takes it a PayPal right it's
processed by PayPal
don't get your credit card information
or anything like that I don't want that
it's handled all with PayPal so you know
why you want to join order flows is
because you see the power of order flow
analysis and how it can change your
trading you want to understand what's
happening in the markets you're excited
to find low-risk trading opportunities
and basically you want a life of freedom
and fulfillment if you can make trading
to work for you
and again you know people say well you
know it's expensive it's really not you
know money comes money goes right if you
really want something you'll find the
money for it you know it's like if if
your neighbor that drives the Mercedes
says hey I'll send you my Mercedes for
$5,000 and you know it's worth fifty
thousand you don't have the money you'll
find it right because you know you're
getting tremendous value out of that and
again I'm not saying you know max out
your credit cards no you know used money
that you have you know but money Commons
money goes you know you're gonna get
paid in a couple weeks you know if you
don't want to put money aside to
actually learn something you'll learn a
skill that you know you could use you
know forever basically that that's the
decision you gotta make so thanks for
watching if you want to download my book
you go to order Flo's calm slash book on
HTML you'll have to enter your email
you'll be joining my list so that you
know what I have any announcements or
anything you you'll be messaged for it
honestly it's you know it's good to have
you know it's good and be on my list I
think you know cuz I do presentations
quite frequently and you know I try to
keep presentations I try to talk about a
little something different each time so
you know hopefully you can pick up a
nugget here and there out of the
different presentations so you know
economic go to order flows calm slash
all in and you know any questions email
my can order flows calm and again you
know goodbye the software go to order
flows calm slash all in dot html' so
thanks everyone and have a great day
bye-bye